[Music]
lee is in st louis hi lee welcome to the
ramsey show
hey lee hey dave how's it going great
man what's up
hey so my wife and i own a small
catering business we do a lot of big
corporations we go to a place like
walmart and fedex and we've been pretty
successful with it for the past few
years and we're looking to buy some
ground and build a house
and i was just curious on what your take
is on buying ground versus how much to
spend versus building a house
well when the uh when the whole thing is
done
the mortgage that you end up with
does not need to be more than a fourth
of your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
rate
and okay the ratio of ground to house
can vary
uh and you know if you're if you're
buying a big track of ground obviously
that you're probably going to have a
higher ratio of land cost versus house
than you would if you bought a simple
lot and built on it a subdivision lot
generally is going to be around 20
of the total price
if you buy you know a standard
subdivision lot if you spend
you know a hundred thousand bucks on a
how on a lot you're going to drop about
a half million dollars you're gonna have
a half million dollar project total so
about 400 000 on the house that's about
that's a fairly standard ratio but it's
not a rule
and there's nothing wrong with it being
different if you want to buy a big track
of ground and build a small house on it
because you wanted a farm type setting
there's nothing wrong with that at all
that doesn't mean you did something
yeah we're quite a bit ways out of st
louis and uh so we're going to be by a
three acre track of wood
and then
uh reworking the ground and building our
dream home on there cool
good
yeah so uh we're hoping to get the land
for about sixty thousand and then uh
build our house on that so i know yeah
the ratio between land and house
i mean it
what are you thinking you're going to
spend on the house on the construction
uh
you know we're hoping you know between
you know 400 000 i think
that's what we're gonna be comfortable
with after after getting the land um so
that's about that's about a 20 ratio
again you're not far off of that yeah
so um you're a little higher on that but
it's not it's not the other world
everything you're saying is fine i mean
um
in some cases you may be in you're in an
area where the you're far enough out
that the land cost has gone down you're
three acres for 60 grand anywhere in
america that's a pretty good deal
you know and so
uh where we're about outside of st louis
are you
effingham illinois
oh yeah absolutely yeah we've got an
affiliate there yeah
very good yeah uh
yeah so we're just listed by a little
check of land and start our start our
dream home
absolutely
i don't see anything any reason not to
do it as long as when you're finished
460 thousand dollars is
on a mortgage on a 15 year with
depending on how much cash you put into
the deal but your net mortgage
cannot be more than a fourth of your
take-home pay should not be more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fix because otherwise you
end up house poor
yeah and we experienced that we we did
an episode on the fine print on the
housing gold rush and we talked to
people who got into these houses we've
taken calls where people go dave i'm 50
of my take-home pays going towards this
mortgage and it's crushing me so that's
it really comes down to the ratios and
math on this where you can breathe and
you have margin to attack your other
goals and invest and give and do all
these things to where the house payment
isn't bearing down on you it's a big
deal